thank you guys it's good to be here my
name is Hans Kim I live in a van
hashtag van like Instagram catch me on
the ground I live in a van so that I can
pursue comedy full-time so if you don't
think I'm funny I'm sorry I'm trying
really hard
no excuses I know someone's at the back
like yeah that's funny but not living
your man funny could've written that
joke in an apartment buddy it's hard to
date inside of a van because ladies love
shelter so even if the date goes well
what usually ends up happening is we go
for a drive until I can work up the
courage to tell her we arrived 45
minutes ago today you know this is kind
of tricky I used to date a woman who's
really into yoga and choke sex and was
like do you enjoy breathing or not may I
remind you millennial
these days you know dating is great I my
friends always like Hans you do learn
how to talk to women maybe or maybe
women could learn how to listen to Hans
well you gonna try to hear about the
Federal Reserve so complicated is a lot
going on there I was talking to this
lady she was like did you know that my
vagina is a 3d printer because they can
make a baby say actually your womb is
the 3d printer your vagina is the Train
it only prints one thing with lots of
errors there's nine months to print it
and the whole time it's printing is
complaining hey this is sanded on City
trays at night I love having sex but 99%
my sex career was so low and now I have
to orgasm while some was breathing on me
I know what my name is you know they
don't think you stinky
it's time Logan any valves sure I mean I
don't think I don't think I could ever
have sex on the dude sorry fellas I've
never looked at a beautiful woman a bit
like she's gorgeous but is there a
version of her that's bigger and hairier
and there's less kindness I'll put on my
bottle never happens fine it's hard to
date as an Asian man everyone thinks
Asian women are beautiful not ever think
they should matter beautiful which
doesn't make any sense because anything
Asian women are created be [ __ ] I'm
crucial part of the sexy process
[Music]
[Laughter]
please sometimes feed me exactly our
children will be very beautiful happily
than half will be great engineers and
that's important
I like how occasion women they act like
there's such hot [ __ ] in America but
back home we're throwing you away you
don't impress me you look like us the
same I can throw on a wing and be a
seven-five white dudes to it just don't
want to the purpose I don't understand
homophobia this one guy was like dude
we're so lucky we're not gay can you
imagine if most of the gender we were
attracted to wasn't attracted to his
back
I was like whoa can't even imagine it
[Music]
was cry all the time those losers I
don't understand what people will say
it's Adam and Eve not Adam and Steve
because Adam and Eve we're not even a
good couple pickle queen okay first of
all they disobeyed God and the inner
fruit they weren't supposed to eat which
is kind of gay
they raise Cain and Abel and Cain
murdered Abel
why do I take a parenting advice from
people raised a murderer
there are only three other people on
earth become the core of the world's
population you starting to get your [ __ ]
together my my sister's a Christian then
she is though what would Jesus do
bracelet but I very rarely see you're
behaving like a Jewish carpenter fella
burn how to speak Hebrew do something
speak he's working an Asian woman she
went on a mission trip recently which is
where Americans go to different
countries to get new profile pictures
Mike's Christian and her family owns
Asian people which is kind of weird
because the people wrote the Bible
didn't even seem to know that Asians
existed they couldn't even drop us a
line Haeju is rich I'm on the fireworks
really proud of you guys back to the
Jews my favorites know things about the
Jews I mean I love the Bible you know
they say it's a good book but I think
old man the sea was better what kind of
book introduces the main character
two-thirds of the Wayans and the novel
and then kills them off right away four
times in a row and they ran out the book
with fan fiction why don't you came and
finish your own book and some dude voted
in free it's cheap
I'm an atheist now because it's not a
kindergarten and I have an internet
connection
I think it'd be stressful to have an
ideology that can be destroyed by facts
[Laughter]
I think capitalism is great if you want
to do it I think that's fine but don't
make everyone play your stupid game
I like fortnight I don't make your
grandma play take away our house issue
is I like how Americans will say
communism never works as if we didn't
spend billions of dollars and kill
billions of people to make sure we don't
work
remember the war in Vietnam Cuba Panama
Nicaragua we're pretty anxious about it
now work it we're giving it 110 percent
communism never works because whenever
people control the means of production
their democratically elected leaders
mysteriously died and a small rebel
group always finds automatic weapons and
luck they handle themselves or in the
stable is operate to stabilize
I am NOT a communist but I do support
any policies that Republicans considered
communism which is whenever two or more
people gathered to do something nice I
think it's funny that Tanner is a white
person's name Tanna then white you white
[ __ ] you're like hey this is my
Mexican friend Tanner black fantana's
I'm Asian or the nose country nice I'm
from the Province in China called South
korea-japan province
I have a South Korean so you can say I'm
a southerner yeah its way to things I
like kpop eschewed commies I'm
southerner hello rednecks cuz rednecks
can survive in any wilderness situation
you put them in they're so versatile
except the situation where everyone has
equal rights I kind of [ __ ] them up
with an alligator I can't live in a cold
aside with a minority so try smiling I
mean I love all the things in America
they say in prison don't drop the soap
that's not even helpful it should be
don't pick up the soap drop in sylvans
you want is the bending over where they
really get you you're still gonna get
right you're just gonna really clean
hands on happens
are these rapist like man I want to get
that kid but he never drops the soap no
I am Asian you know it's just pretty
cool
I give me a butt of a lot breeding dogs
which I understand can be very horrific
to Americans because in America dogs are
treated like family members but in Asia
we treat our family and presenting
family members just a little cultural
thing we do
instead of buying an animal we love my
grandma to their modern age unless
you're maybe gonna let me see you throw
you in the river suit you better don't
like it there everything's chaotic I'm
not a racist
of course I hate people too I just get
to go there first
you hate people for their skin I need
people for their souls I'm gonna get to
my level
I was I saw a book in Arabic and an
airport recently which freaked me out
but then I saw pull the corner of the
page put the book away and I was like oh
thank god he's got future plans by the
power of literature
those bows I love the Black Panther
movie because they gave black children a
hero they could finally woke up - and
not just someone like Rob Luther King
jr. Malcolm X or Harriet Tubman or Rosa
Parks or Jared Marshall effectively
Robinson Willie Mays no there's a person
[Laughter]
[Music]
what are they going to I love white
people I think having white pride is a
good thing but a lot of people do it
incorrectly you know there are something
like the Nazis or the Confederate flags
and every building a castle or yodeling
that's not white pride that's racism
you're not three white to be racist I
can hit the juice I know I can
it's not a white thing annoying I I
think it's good to talk about different
things like immigration you know I don't
understand people who want everyone to
speak English because they're never the
people that want to have a conversation
with the foreigner they're never like to
speak English so I can better get to
know about Diwali the festival of lights
those language barriers killing me
you really want everyone on this bus to
be able to talk to you right now you
speak Hungarian and go over there I'm
from New York City you could say I'm a
New Yorker thank you I I like how they
have extra security in New York City on
9/11 as if it's the date that's the
problem notice how many 911s happen in
September it's crazy the heat terrace
looking to the cow
[Applause]